if you have a hard time staying inspired
and motivated I'm going to share with
you today
the 100 songs that I listen to to keep
me going I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I've been
getting a lot of comments recently from
people asking me to share my belief
playlists now I've talked about this
list a lot in some of my older videos
where I really think that having a
schedule that builds you up every day is
really important to you being able to
achieve your goals and one of the first
things that I do in my schedule every
day is I turn on music I find that music
is a great way to instantly change your
state and get you excited about the day
that's ahead so I've made a list called
the belief playlist that I play every
single day to help get me going and so
finally I'm gonna share it with you guys
now keep in mind these are songs and
videos that inspire me this list was
never intended to be made public their
songs that make me dance that make me
move my head that make me want to get up
and sing along you should find your own
songs as well they get you moving that
you could put on every morning to
instantly change your state and get you
ready to have an amazing day so the link
to the playlist is right here and I'd
also love to know what your favorite
songs are that get you moving and get
you energized to get your mojo on leave
your favorite songs in the comments
below and maybe I'll be honest a new
track to the belief playlists believe
thank you guys so much for watching
remember to leave those songs in the
comments and if you want to see more
videos like this don't forget to
subscribe to the channel I'll see you
soon one last quick thing for the belief
playlist I'll always sort it randomly so
the songs are listed in order of
popularity and then as soon as I start
playing they come on randomly so that
it's not always the same order and it
adds a little bit of spice so if you're
gonna start playing it put it on random
so you get some fun things and not just
the most popular ones at the top that's
it enjoy
self-improvement books are like fitness
books they never work on their own what
you need is a trainer that's Evan get
the newsletter
you